le problème de l'excrétion au moyen-âge
n'en est pas un puisque l'exhibition des
organes génitaux
qu'il s'agisse des hommes ou des femmes
ne posent aucune espèce de questions
vous savez bien que les sous vêtements
pour les femmes n'existe pas et que le
verbe troussé à cette époque tout son
sens délicieux et pour les hommes
eh bien mon dieu il y a des culottes il
ya des eaux de chaud ce qui montre
manifestement qu'ils sont assez bien
pourvus pour certain regard on ne
catcher rial alors que notre pantalon
actuelle naturellement du destin donc on
se libère quand on veut où on veut et
d'abord chez soi contre la muraille ça
ce n'est pas un problème dans la
cheminée surtout la cheminée sert énorme
est mort et il faut bien se dire qu'au
moyen-âge le feu est un danger perpétuel
je suppose que le soir toute la famille
d'épicés en choeur pour que les braises
delattre soit vraiment est apte à chaque
fois qu'un incendie ont dû vivre du
moulinage ces trois quarts de la ville
qui paraissent comme vous le savez il
vaut mieux que toute source de ce
disparaissent et puis enfin il a fait
tout de même la fenêtre je ne comprends
pas que les gens qui habitent un
pavillon où une maison de campagne se
prive de ce plaisir associé l'un des
meilleurs de la vie ouvrir grande la
fenêtre et s'exonérer largement au moyen
âge c'est absolument classique et les
passants bien entendu je reçois ce que
vous pensez eyi ils crient ils
protestent ils vont commencer à porter
ses très forts quand la france va se
doter d'un service de police à partir de
mika thor dieu danse de police s 160
qu'il va y avoir des inspecteurs qui
vont faire des rondes des commissaires
qui vont entrer dans les maisons alors
le tribunal de simple police va
fonctionner parce que jo ne sont pas
très contents de recevoir ce que vous
pensez cependant il y à la maison des
lieux ils peuvent être au
rez-de-chaussée ils peuvent être un
billet taj mais à partir du xvième
siècle sont très souvent au grenier
parce que les médecins disent ce sont
eux qui s'occupent de ces questions que
l'odeur n'est ce pas on ira beaucoup
plus vite si on place les
et commodité au galetas voilà le bordel
mais il ya aussi le problème de la
vidange des fosses parce que les faux
sont devenus obligatoires par une série
d'ordonnancés royal depuis le 14e siècle
et françois 1er il ya tenu très fort la
main des milliers de fausses qu'il faut
vider à la main mesdames à la main et au
saut toujours des hommes mais la matière
parce que vous avez été très dangereux
étant donné les gars méphitique se
dégage dès qu'on nous vend la fosse et
qui peuvent causer la mort des
compagnons gars douar qui accompagnent
leurs patrons qu'on appelle m fifi alors
cette joyeuse brigade une fois son
travail terminé s'en va jusqu à
montfaucon à paris et vous savez
montfaucon c'est loin c'est au c'est du
côté des buttes chaumont
alors de temps en temps on aurait
peut-être la tentation de si le guen ne
veuille pas dans le caniveau ou si on
passe près de la scène
allez les gars allons-y vite dans la
scène et on arrive comme ça jusqu'au
montfaucon n'y a plus grand-chose de
travail est assez vite fait ça va se
passer très longtemps comme ça vous
savez jusqu'en 1850
car montfaucon ne disparaîtra quand 1850
à ce moment-là paris à un million
d'habitants
un million d'habitants qui reçoivent
parfois surtout aux voix douce voyez au
mois d'août les faons les vents
dominants qui passent là et qu'ils se
rabattent sur les champs elysées sur
l'ouest parisien
je sais bien venu quartier alors on va
se poser le problème à ce moment là
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas trouver
autre chose et ce sera le tout à l'égout
la grande aventure du tout dans l'écho
le tout à l'égout qui va être menée à
partir de second empire
parce que nous allons nous doter d'un
système au moins à paris absolument
magnifique unique au monde nous sommes
les premiers pour les échos jeudi
hautement aujourd'hui je tiens à le
souligner à la face du monde
nous avons le meilleur système d'égouts
qui soit plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres on pourrait même y organiser
des promenades ce tout à l'égout va
d'abord faciliter la disparition des
eaux pluviales et des eaux ménagères
mais certains ingénieurs vont évidemment
pousser le raisonnement jusqu'au bout
pour
quoi ne pas brancher chaque immeuble sur
le tout à l'égout ainsi la fosse
disparaîtra et on éloignera de la ville
tous ces miasmes putride et dangereux
parce qu'à bâtir de pasteur on sait que
cette fois nous avons les petits
microbes tous sont chez nous est ce que
nous allons les garder dans nos fossés
petits microbes
nous avons là une pompe qui peut
attaquer nos chers petits leur apporter
la paix de la variole typhoïde que
sais-je encore alors éloignons cela vite
par le tout à l'égout on va s'en aller à
achères on va se donner dans la seine
vers les champs d'épandage et c'est un
système qui va être obligatoire à paris
loi de 1894 préparé par poubelle un très
grand préfet pour lequel j'ai une
référence révérence l'extraordinaire
l'inventeur de la boîte n'est pas auquel
il a donné son nom est aussi là des
théoriciens du tout à l'égout
à partir de là paris devient vraiment et
on a filmé ses gonds respirer lumière
parce que dans l'éclairage d'abord au
gardien suisse électricité et puis ma
foi un courant d'eau vous ne regardez
pas le cas ni vous pas qu'il n'aurait
paris - moi je les regarde et
franchement j'en tire prendre sa
distinction je respire quand je viens
des hauteurs de belleville
c'est un spectacle pour moi
[Musique]